les mantes et élémentaires sont appelés
à élire leur nouveau conseil municipal
un scrutin le 15 mai prochain après la
démission du maire raphaël cogner en
janvier dernier une démission suite à
des divisions au sein de la majorité
mais le maire démissionnaire sera
candidat pour partir sur un nouveau
projet qu'on a fait avec mon équipe un
certain nombre de panneaux par thèmes et
les gens qui rentrent nous notre des
post it et nous disent des propositions
ça veut pas dire que tout sera possible
mais ça veut dire que les montées sont
très intéressés par ce qui se passe dans
leur vie ils ont beaucoup de
propositions à faire beaucoup de choses
à dire d'après il ya deux sujets qui me
tiennent à coeur particulièrement la
question du commerce ici on est en
centre ville mais il ya du commerce sur
l'ensemble de la ville donc il faut qu
on est notre commerce de centre-ville et
notre commerce du val fourré aussi j'y
tiens beaucoup parce que le centre
commercial mans 2 2 est un lieu très
important il faut qu'on aide de façon
très précoce les enfants jeunes c'est
tous nos dispositifs des devoirs et
réussite éducative mais aussi qu'on
permette à ceux qui ont quitté le
système éducatif de reprendre des
formations et c'est pour ça que on a
proposé l'ouverture d'une école du
numérique pour remettre en formation des
jeunes qui apprennent un métier qu'ils
puissent retrouver le chemin de l'emploi
parmi les membres de la majorité
sortante en désaccord avec le maire
jean-luc santini avec la liste montrent
unis pour l'avenir avec lui huit
adjoints de la dernière majorité
repartent dans sa liste avec notamment
pierre bédier objectif s'inscrire dans
la continuité
en 2020 on a été élu sur un programme
on n'a pas bien compris justement
pourquoi le maire ne souhaitait pas
appliquer le programme pour lequel on a
été on a été élu donc l'idée c'est bien
la continuité de ce programme les
dossiers prioritaires c'est le logement
bien sûr le logement puisque autant il y
a des problèmes au val fourré sur le
redémarrage du renouvellement urbain qui
est un petit peu en panne depuis des
années donc une priorité le
renouvellement urbain du val fourré mais
aussi le centre ville puis la sauvegarde
du commerce a un qui va évidemment pas
très très bien comme bounan beaucoup de
villes mais à menton à on a l ambition
c'est d'avoir un commerce dynamique
autre liste portée par la république en
marche pour vous pour mantes mené par
françois gerber dans son équipe des
personnes de la société civile des chefs
d'entreprise novice en politique ils
veulent s'inscrire dans la rupture on
propose autre chose proposer autre chose
ça veut dire des gens nouveaux qu'ils
sont qui ne font pas partie de des
équipes sortantes le logement parce que
il y à il ya une anormalité et une
absence de transparence dans
l'affectation des logements sociaux
l'écologie de terrain parce que la
perception écologique et là la
préoccupation écologique n'a jamais été
présentes de la part des élus sortants
et les écoles parce que les écoles
maternelles et primaires sont dans une
situation catastrophique au niveau
matériel ça c'est un truc qui nous
remontent des parents et les enseignants
à côté de ces listes classé à droite et
au centre trois listes sont classés à
gauche